[Music] It's
not him. I heard about it from his wife.But one
day, almost every day,
scams
started flying into his backyard.  Well, at
first it wasn't every day, but when I saw the cat
coming to drink water, it started coming many times, and it
seems that they decided to make the cat the main character's partner.  There
was only one thing that Miyazaki taught me about doing this work, and what that was was that I was writing an
autobiography,
and that I was writing a story about myself.  That's
probably what I meant by portraying the people I met during that time, from when I was born to where I am today.And then,
somewhere along the line, I would think that I would appear
somewhere, but I never expected it to be
treated in such a big way.  I didn't expect to be fooled by
him, and I was surprised by his observational skills.I knew it.I knew it, but when Aosaki
told me that the model was actually me, he was surprised.  I was surprised,
even though I knew that, but the main character Masato
and Aosaki's interactions incorporated a lot of my normal conversations.And
that was the timing.I was often
criticized, so I looked at myself objectively.  I
decided to watch it.In that sense, it
was interesting.It was ranked number one, so I
thought I had to take it in.But
what if I released a movie before that?It's the first
new movie in 10 years, and the audience...
A lot of people came to the movie theater,
so I guess
that's why everyone was happy.That's what I thought at first.After that,
opinions started to appear on the Internet and were posted there.  I
had to watch it one more time, I had to watch it one more time.I
thought, ``I don't understand everything after watching it once'', and I thought that more and more customers
would come to see this.  I'm sure that's true,
but why did
so many people come to me? Even before we approached them,
many people said they wanted to do it and
came together. Naturally, this is
Miyazaki's first work in 10 years.  I guess that was the
big thing. It was
a little different from usual. I
guess I would say it's Miyazaki even more than usual. I'd sit at my desk all morning and
draw that picture.  But
this time, I'm in a nervous room, and I wonder if there's
a lot going on with the staff, and I
keep smiling while communicating
[Music], and I
wonder whether I make it by hand or on a computer.  At the
end of the day, you
can't do anything good unless you have a strong heart at the root.This is my basic way of thinking,
but there are areas where this can only be done with CG, and this can
only be done by hand.  To
put it simply, in this case, a human emerges from inside the bird, which can only be
drawn by hand, in a way that
cannot be done with CG.So,
I think I'll be able to develop each one in a different way.
[Music]
I think. I
'm really happy. First of all,
a lot of people ask me the reason for that.
But in the end, I think it's because I have faith in humanity.
Actually,
until yesterday, I thought...  We were traveling together, and it was already
very difficult.He talked all morning and night, and he
wouldn't let me sleep at night.Thanks to you, I'm tired today, and
I can't walk anymore.